you said you protect and provide do you
not think it would be better if your son
had a father in his life or daughter
I would love so much for him to the five
if you go like I've I'm lucky enough to
have men and family members that are
male in my life to be able to show them
that kind of way but sometimes I do
think I wish like every day I wish I
wish I had someone there yeah that
showed him that side of it but I'm quite
masculine in that kind of energy like
when it comes to projected and whatever
I will I'll I'll do more Manda but I
know what you mean that that it I don't
know is it because it's weird we're best
for Mars mom's like you follow oh no not
me get up just on yours I'm quite I kind
of try and make it balanced to do before
um but I do wish it did ever
a better was there red flags because a
lot of women say this year but I
guarantee there was some kind of signs
that he was that guy that doesn't keep
his promises there was always red flags
but like Jordan wasn't planned I would
not plan to have a child at that point
not talking about the commitment in
general I'm talking about like the
commitment side and the keeping his word
side I guarantee there was red flags
that was the question in hand like would
you would you not want to get married
first I would have gained nothing from a
marriage but do you think it would have
been different if it was I I also to the
guys as well do you think it changes if
a child comes unplanned
the way you look at having a child yeah
because to me yeah I would have had one
if not yeah yeah because I feel like
that changes the question as well
because I feel like if you know you want
to have a kid then you can mentally
prepare okay sick I'm gonna yeah I'm
gonna provide if this comes unplanned
yet if I was a man not to say that I
would run out and be like see you later
[ __ ] but um but I do think that
let's say yeah we we have been seeing
each other for like a year or something
she becomes pregnant
um there for example I don't want to I
don't want to have a kid now she wants
to have the kid I'll I'll help her
because I don't want to leave and be the
[ __ ] that's like by
um but then when it comes to you know
you're eight months in and this child is
gonna come in like a month I would be
[ __ ] [ __ ] my pants yeah because
it changes the combo you know because
you can't mentally prepare and you I
still don't say that they should leave
never but I do think it really depends
on what's this baby planned because that
changes because
I mean the idea is like we're 100 in
control of birth yeah so whether you had
it or not it wasn't yeah I we had the
conversation I said right these are the
options
are we making a go of it like what's
happening we had the full conversation
we had full 50 50 import and we're like
if you want me to get I will do you know
what I mean and then we had the import
and then it would come to the conclusion
and we will try our best to make a
family for this channel yeah and it did
not work and you said there were red
flags before yeah
I'm not trying to like come at you like
no no I'm just I'm just saying like a
lot of times like as women yeah we'll
kind of make it seem like we're a victim
in a situation
right right but I'm saying I'm just
saying I'm saying in general yeah but
like like there are red flags that
happen before and we we choose to move
forward yeah so it's not like a gotcha
like he got you it's like okay
what kind of evading the the whole
argument like so look I think we gotta
put some wholeness on the men as well
there's two types of man there's one
that lives up to his word and there's
one that doesn't simple as that yeah but
I think you could um what's your name
sorry in the green Andrew
Angie Angie I think you could learn
something from this so basically I think
what a lot of people but especially
women are missing is the ability to sow
seeds right they don't sell seeds they
don't think long term they just think
like oh yeah and now I feel so this I
feel so dark but you were saying that at
19 yeah I wanted one kid now it's I
don't want nothing your brain's not
fully developed
it's something it's gonna sound rude but
like there's some studies that say till
25 your brain is still developing so
there's some shots you're just gonna
have to take I was gonna is this a
battlefield hold on let me just finish
if it's a battlefield and you know
people are running at you there's some
shots you're gonna have to take you
haven't got 100 accuracy all right
you're gonna have to start just licking
off licking it off because when you get
to 55 like four years ago you was
thinking one now it's zero three is I
need a half
so sometimes you need to think about
sowing seeds and and be open-minded I
think a lot of young people sorry to
like you're not trying to play it down
I'm 26 but it's absolutely
one of you in this room proves me wrong
or makes me think differently I'm going
to allow myself to think and listen but
a lot of people are too hard-headed
about something and that's why at 55
they're regret now
I wanted to add to what you just said
though because the the obviously I feel
like a lot of women I'm not a woman but
I feel like a lot evidently well I feel
like a lot of women will get to a
certain like there will be a switch at
some point like you'll be playing with
your your friend's kid or your kid a
cute baby on on Instagram or something
like that and then you're like when you
get past it when you get past 35 it does
come in it's it's you could you don't
have a choice anymore or like as the
older you get the choices goals but it
depends on your situation I have a
couple stats for you guys
um
what do you guys think the average age
is of first child or like to give birth
in the West in England
under the age of 25. first kid as you
think okay
um between 20 um 25 to 27.
thanks okay
um 28 to 30.
or above maybe uh 30 to 35. okay okay
it's it's 30. that's the um the average
age in 2022 the average age for a woman
to give birth is 30. and it's growing up
um and at 30
um 90 of your eggs are gone wow
the rate of women giving birth in their
20s has decreased while giving birth in
their 30s and 40s has exploded
only 11 of women that freeze their eggs
end up with a live birth at the end of
the process yeah that's good and how
much how much does freezing eggs cost
around a round of Ivy a round of IVF
costs around twelve thousand dollars on
average in the United States is that the
price the price of an IVF at the private
you at the price of a round of IVF in
the UK at a private clinic clinic is
about five thousand pounds a lot less
than the US
okay okay everyone needs to get me
pregnant guys
have you ever considered the risks of
geriatric pregnancy and did you know
those stats so raise your hand if you
knew those stats well is that geriatric
pregnancy
um is pregnancy after 35. yeah and my
mate's mom had her at four and she's 16
she's perfectly fine
exceptions no it's not the rules
okay okay okay so should I do it all
right all right all right so my my
parents also have given birth like my
parents and their grandparents have
given birth late like my both of my
grandparents no I I understand but I
wouldn't bet on it why would I bet on
that that's stupid
maybe it wasn't your time to have kids
yet some people not red tough kids till
they later how is it it's your choice
exactly
right and I'm saying that's fine but
don't complain about the results
Jennifer Aniston is that's what she she
is not just one person and that's what
I'm saying no girls do it all the time
you
how many girls you see crying on Tick
Tock everyone every girl here you guys
are all pretty enough that you know
someone in your friend zone that's ready
to marry you tomorrow
I think that's true though because I
want kids I want them now but I just I'm
not gonna just have a kid for this baby
I need to when you're ready like I want
the family so I think it's unfair to say
that it's my choice it's not my choice
because yeah I could have a kid with you
if I wanted to sorry to pick you up
is
I need to be in love with you you know I
want the whole the whole package I don't
want just a sperm donor because if
that's the case I'll go to a bank
okay but it's a choice because there are
mat I'm sure you have men that want to
date you right I'm sure I mean I'm sure
you have them I'm sure you have men that
you know are good guys in your friend
zone no I don't want to [ __ ] them and I
understand but then it's like it's it's
basically like the men you don't want
don't want you yep no and it's it's
everyone everyone that's single if the
man if the man you wanted wanted you you
would be in a relationship with them not
necessarily it's like it's like women we
don't as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
ever every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible